today's draft the match-up draft for
super bowl 55 i'll give you the first
pick
okay thank you very much uh definitely
and scotty miller he is fast there's no
doubt but you're
not as fast as tyree kill i i think um
the first one i gotta go with is just
the chiefs o line versus the bucks front
four
just right there that that to me it's
it's one of the hugest stories of the
football game
yeah listen tampa can't blitz patrick
mahomes
you can't blitz him they blitzed him the
first time around
and he torched them every time they did
it right pete i talked about it in my
podcast i think he was six for nine
against the blitz
for like 120 something yards and two
touchdowns
you can't do it the extra guy you send
on the blitz
no leave him back to cover tyree kill
who burned you for 200 yards in the
first quarter
they can't the front four they got all
these guys
if they want to win this game it's gonna
have to be
like giants against the patriots you
know
or giants beating the buffalo bills back
in the day only thing is you got a
quarterback here that can move and make
people miss but
that is the matchup of the game for me
and the bucks have to win it
and have to dominate it i think in a way
almost to win the football game
you think about the giants patriots from
the 2007 season
the game that kept the patriots from
getting to 19-0
and to me it's that that opportunity for
tom brady
to get a little revenge against the guy
who drew up the defense steve spagnola
versus tom brady and steve spagnolos got
the guys to get after tom brady chris
jones up the middle that's the key up
the middle brady knows how to avoid
the pressure on the outside when it's
coming up the middle there isn't much he
can do
so spagnolo versus brady 13 years later
brady gets his shot at revenge chris
yeah
i i hear you the the brady verse spags
mental match up
where hey honestly spags has got the
better of them there there's there's no
doubt
he got the better of them earlier this
year hey tampa got
into success in that game when the
chiefs were up 17
nothing the the chiefs took the the
pedal off the medal
and got into these real vanilla defenses
for a while and let the tampa offense
get jump started and going
but when they were exotic and blitzing
uh there was some crapping of the pants
going on by the buccaneers offense
that's where i'm gonna go too for the
next one i'm going back to the
the buxo line versus the chiefs d line
the bucks gotta run the ball in this
game
they have to the more and more i look at
this game i think that bucks almost have
to play this game like the giants in
super bowl 25.
it really is that way it's stop that
pass
game run the ball control the clock and
that's the one thing they didn't do or
put their money in the first time around
i think running the ball is going to be
paramount to them
beating spags stopping some of his
trickeration on that
the running game will settle down some
of his exotic defenses
you know we talk about tyree kill and
travis kelsey and how do you take one
away
how do you take both away you can't take
both away the bills took neither away
devon white versus travis kelsey i think
that's going to be such a key match up
here
getting devin white in his face maybe
you know just
just giving him a little bit of business
early on give him something to think
about maybe he'll drop a pass or two
because
he's thinking where's devon white and
we've seen him from time to time who
have that uncharacteristic moment
where the ball squirts out of his hands
you want to maybe get him into that
mindset where he makes a mistake or two
and starts thinking too much
so white versus kelsey that may be the
recipe to slow down that aspect of the
kansas city office yeah i
i hear you there i i do i mean that's
that's going to be
one of the things to watch for kansas
city does such a good job
of moving kelsey and hill around and
then also putting them on the same side
of the field sometimes to where
it's hard to double them and do crazy
stuff it really is
so that'll be interesting to see what
they do in defending him and will they
trust devin white
i'm going to go like a similar thing to
you there mike i'm gonna go with carlton
davis versus tyree kill
yeah i mean i hope he's not in as many
one-on-one opportunities as he was the
first time around against tyree kill
um but that again there's gonna be a few
plays
no matter much how much they try to
protect him where he's going to be by
himself to a degree
and how he does in those one-on-one
moments i do think goes a long way to
dictating who wins the game and by how
much
now look i i this one duplicates one of
yours but it's more
specific because one of the things that
that i got the biggest kick out of this
week was
jpp versus the guy who he doesn't know
mike rummers right now now pierre paul's
still got to play he's the only guy that
didn't practice yesterday for the tampa
bay buccaneers
he's got that knee injury the rest of
the guys practiced at least on a limited
basis he didn't practice but jpp versus
mike rummers when you think back
to super bowl 50 with mike remembers
getting owned by the broncos pass raj
this could be
this could be deja vu all over again in
a bad way for mike remembers chris
no it's it's a scary thing the the only
that's where
i mean it's the match up to watch but
what's different
is like what colleeus campbell talked
about you got a quarterback who's a
magician back there
who makes pressure look makes it look
like it's not pressure
it's we've never seen anything like it
so that's where it's going to be really
fun to watch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports